joining us now this reaction is Michael
nose host of the Michael Noel's show as
much as I want to hear from you actually
want to hear sing a few more lines baby
it's cold oh it's it's pretty good I'll
take going on I think the problem right
now is that in 2018 the left is short on
ears and long on mouths so they're so
eager to be offended they're so eager to
protest they're not listening to what
they're protesting with Rudolph they're
missing the point they hear that Rudolph
talks about bigotry it talks about
bullying the point of Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer is that bigotry is a
bad thing they they don't understand
that the coquettish banter in baby it's
cold outside is about how both the man
and the woman both want to stay and
canoodle a little bit longer this is
also because the left doesn't quite
understand virtue or modesty or
seduction here so the woman in that song
it's constantly saying well maybe I'll
have half a drink more maybe I'll have a
cigarette more she wants to stick around
too but there are social mores of the
time she is resisting she's teasing the
man and the man is trying to seduce her
but this is all almost beside the point
the left is trying to say that baby it's
cold outside is misogynistic it has
nothing to do with that Snoop Dogg has a
song about how women are prostitutes for
men's sexual pleasure you don't see the
left
protesting Snoop Dogg this is an
extension of the war on Christmas which
is an expression of the left's disdain
for traditional Western culture any of
the pop radio stations right now I mean
baby it's cold outside is offensive but
what about what's on the radio right now
and getting the top ratings I mean I
turn it off but that's that's exactly
right that's exactly right go go after a
charming classic about men and women who
love one another and this has always
been frustrating to the left
the major feminist theorist Shulamit
Firestone said that love is the major
impediment to women's liberation and so
they're very frustrated because they're
never going to get their gender war
because in the gender war everybody is
sleeping with the enemy
you know the classics right off they're
saying it's offensive because of
bullying but isn't that what the story
is about they're talking about how he is
bullied for having his red nose but then
one foggy Christmas Eve you know Santa's
become she overcomes that because of
this this culture he leads the charge I
mean isn't this applauding act and
condemning bullying why why would we get
rid of this they don't listen long
enough to hear that part they only
listen to the first part they haven't
made it all the way to the end and this
is this is this trigger-happy nature
right now especially on the left they're
unwilling to hear their opponents out
they're unwilling to hear the other side
and they're so disdainful of traditional
culture they're so angry I think they
need to relax a little bit have a nice
mug of eggnog and listen to the whole
song they'll realize that they have
nothing to be offended out about in the
first place
I love it well Santa doesn't get consent
to come down the chimney so Santa's
probably out next year breaking and
entering
you're right all right Michael no let's
appreciate your time though thank you
sir